este es uno de los edificios que ha
quedado dañado en este ataque a este
complejo residencial de la ciudad de
crematorio la ciudad más importante de
la región del donbass en control del
gobierno de ucrania este cohete había
caído en la mitad de este parque que
está rodeado por estos edificios y si se
ve cada una de las ventanas ha quedado
impactada dañada muchos vidrios caídos y
bueno el que veíamos fue tal vez el que
recibió el mayor impacto que estuvo
quemado una persona que estaba aquí en
este lugar una señora falleció y algunas
personas quedaron heridas y este no fue
el único ataque que sucedió hoy en la
región del donbass en la región en la
ciudad de slogans también fue atacada
también por misiles y cohetes de las
fuerzas rusas y también sucedió en bakú
muta 65 kilómetros de grama toros donde
se centraría en los próximos días la
batalla y donde varias edificaciones
fueron alcanzadas durante la tarde
especialmente por ejemplo unos y también
un centro cultural